jordan peterson announced his new book
uh this week on his youtube channel and
right on cue
a number of employees of the publishing
house i believe it's penguin canada
uh where his book is being published uh
went i don't know it's like the opposite
of ballistic went weepy
and uh and woke and complained
probably that they're safe that they
were endangered by
having such a you know alt-right
transphobe which of course he's not
um be published at the same in the same
place that he that
that they work as if they even have to
read the book or
interact with him in any way so right or
as if publishing
books with bad stuff in it is somehow
not done now
you know right right if they viewed it
as bad then uh
it's still not an argument against
publishing it yeah
so i don't know if we want to say
anything more about that um
but it's we wanted to walk through a few
examples
of um the kind of bad thinking
and bad um you know at some level
collective actions
um that are taking place right now and
the
um presumably decision by at least some
small cabal of employees at penguin
canada
to resist to object to this book
is a perfect example of bad thinking and
you know wow
how did you end up in publishing how did
you end up presumably
caring about literature and books uh if
the idea of a book being published in
the same
under the same name as you draw your
paychecks from
is causing such distress to you it seems
like it seems like you may be in the
wrong field
in the wrong field indeed i will say i
did find something
distressing when i read this news for
the first time
in which news that the news of the
publication by
penguin canada because i regard penguin
canada
as a woeful geographic misinterpretation
of phylogeny and i don't know if it was
puffins or
what that had been misidentified but
frankly
um it's a non-sequitur yeah you okay
there are no penguins in canada not
remotely right but they didn't think so
no they didn't no no obviously it should
not be
up to a bunch of employees who want to
shut down certain
schools of thought to decide what a
publisher can publish the answer is the
publisher
could publish things frankly that the
publisher doesn't believe are
true it should publish them so that you
know if these arguments are
viable that we can have the debate about
what they are and in the case of
peterson this is
so freaking insane if you look at what
his first 12 rules were
yeah you know it's
obviously in the interest of the
well-being of the people that he's
publishing the book
for allow me to take this moment to say
publicly also that i have always stopped
to pet cats when i see them on the
street yes you have
you've been you've been on that rule
since the beginning exactly
[Music]
you